important sur le rapport annexé avec
deux amendements de discussion commune
d'abord chez le président Laurent le 33
merci monsieur le Président alors bon
c'est un amendement évidemment qui vient
à ce moment-là alors qui hier quand nous
avons discuté d'autres articles
notamment l'article 3 avec été introduit
un chapeau
définissant un peu les objectifs
stratégiques donc il aurait été plus
pratique de discuter tout ça en même
temps puisque là il s'agit en fait d'une
définition de ce que pourrait être nos
objectifs de de défense
au-delà de ce qui a été dit dans le
chapeau qui a été adopté hier il y a des
éléments de contradiction avec
avec le chapeau qui a été adopté hier
notamment le fait que nous insistions
dans ce texte sur la liberté de choix de
nos alliances et non pas l'enfermement
dans l'alliance de l'OTAN et je pense
que dans la situation internationale
nous devrions être extrêmement vigilant
sur ça la deuxième chose c'est que nous
fixons en tant que tel comme objectif à
notre politique de défense de travailler
à la relance
d'initiative de prévention des conflits
et de multiplication d'accord
multilatéraux et régionaux de
désarmement donc voilà évidemment des
différences qui auraient mérité de
figurer dans les objectifs globaux
maintenant évidemment comme nous avons
adopté autre chose je ne sais pas si on
peut à ce stade voter cet amendement
mais je voulais en tout cas emporter on
portait dans la discussion les éléments
essentiels qu'il contient je vous
remercie
merci le 7 monsieur Delhaize
merci monsieur le Président il s'agit
simplement de préciser la procédure
retenue pour l'élaboration du projet de
loi de militaire et donc de rappeler
aussi à cette occasion le rôle du
Parlement
merci
avis de la commission sur ces deux
amendements monsieur le président
sur l'amendement 33 monsieur le
Président c'est un avis défavorable
parce que si on partage quelques
éléments d'analyse qui sont proposés par
nos collègues les termes dérivent d'une
mondialisation hyper concurrentielle ne
nous semble pas devoir figurer dans le
rapport annexé en ce qui concerne
l'amendement 7 de la commission des
finances présentées par notre collègue
Dominique delache qui réaffirme que le
président n'est pas seul à prendre ses
responsabilités en matière de
programmation militaire c'est
effectivement un bon amendement sur
lequel nous donnons un avis favorable
car c'est bien un projet de loi que nous
votons et si bien sûr l'initiative vient
du président la proposition est sur
proposition du gouvernement c'est
effectivement le Parlement qui vote la
loi à vie favorable pour ses merci avis
du gouvernement sur ces deux amendements
oui monsieur prison comme j'ai été
bavard je vais de nouveau redevenir
succinct avis défavorable sur les deux
merci
je mets aux voix les deux amendements
d'abord le 33 oui pardon monsieur le
Président Laurent
non parce que le président Cambon est
bien résumé mais on n'est pas obligé de
caricaturer même je ne renie pas la
phrase qu'il a cité mais par exemple la
phrase qui figure pour on citer
certaines dans cette amendement la LPM
s'inscrit dans une visée stratégique
plus globale visant prioritairement la
prévention des conflits la lutte contre
suarmement et pour la multiplication
d'un corps multilatéraux et régionaux de
désarmement est une phrase qui par
exemple n'aurait pas été
inutile dans la description j'ai général
de nos objectifs donc pas de caricature
on peut ne pas être d'accord avec cet
amendement mais il y a quand même une
série d'idées à laquelle on devrait
peut-être prêter un peu d'attention
merci je mets au voie maintenant le 33
avec deux avis défavorables qui est pour
qui est pour
quiconque
le 7 avis de la commission des finances
avec un avis favorable de la commission
défavorable du gouvernement qui est pour
qui contre il est adopté le 53 monsieur
vallée
merci monsieur le Président avec ma
collègue Gisèle Jourdan nous proposons
de remettre à sa place juste c'est à
dire centrale mais pas unique l'Alliance
atlantique n'en sera annexé il faut
d'abord rappeler ce qu'est une alliance
militaire d'une part et c'est qu'elle ne
doit pas nous empêcher de faire pour
défendre nos intérêts nationaux d'autres
parts une alliance militaire défensive
doit dissuader d'attaquer et nourrir
l'esprit de défense collective pour
rendre sa mise en œuvre indubitable en
cas d'attaque l'Allier français dont il
ne devrait même pas être besoin de
préciser qu'il est loyal c'est
parfaitement ce qu'implique son
appartenance à l'alliance et n’hésitera
pas à en assumer les conséquences mais
une alliance militaire n'est pas la
caporalisation des États européens par
l'Allier américain et encore moins or le
champ bien circonscrit de la solidarité
défensive car année après année nous
éprouvons cette difficulté à opposer nos
intérêts aux États-Unis d'Amérique qui
or le temps ne sont pas un allié au sens
militaire mais un partenaire au sens
générique et à notre grand regret pas
toujours de confiance écoute
téléphonique des dirigeants français et
allemand de la NSA sans que ça donne
vraiment de suite ni de scandale
internationalisme agressif pour casser
des fleurons industriels je pense à
Alstom et à la technique des otages
économiques coups de poignard
l'expression n'est pas de moi mais de
Jean-Yves Le Drian que je cite assez
rarement dans l'affaire des sous-marins
australiens et qui se solde par une très
malvenue visite d'État à Washington
ajoutons-y le choix d'un autre
partenaire outre rein dont nous sommes
probablement le seul des deux à penser
que nous formons un couple et qui se
tourne pour ses conséquences dépenses
d'armement ça a été évoqué tout à
l'heure vers des matériels non européens
le rapport annexé doit rappeler plus
fortement que la France est une
puissance pluricontinentale et l'Europe
avec elle distingue la position d'allier
de celle de partenaire et doivent
s'autoriser avec volontarisme à coopérer
plus activement au sud du tropique du
Cancer et le faire comme le définissait
ce grand penseur de la défense qui
régisse de Bray le faire tous azimut et
pas seulement en suivant l'aiguille
indiquant le Nord ou en se vivant comme
allié quand il faut être aussi un
partenaire offensif
merci avis de la commission sur le 53
la commission a donné un avis
défavorable à cet amendement qui semble
remettre en cause le caractère
particulier des alliances de la France
tant dans le cas de l'Union européenne
que de celle de l'OTAN bien évidemment
la France n'étant rien empêchée par son
appartenance à l'alliance de développer
d'autres alliances sous azimut et si on
précisait une telle chose ce serait
plutôt perçu comme une défiance à
l'égard de l'OTAN ce qui n'est
franchement pas approprié dans le
contexte de guerre en Ukraine qui
remettent en cause notre sécurité
collective sur le sol européen c'est un
avis défavorable merci
aux vois le 53 avec deux avis
je fais très court vous m'entendrez plus
appeler mais après mais vous aviez là
Monsieur le Ministre l'occasion de
matiner autrement que par des citations
également tous azimut le gaullisme dont
lequel serait trempé le rapport annexé
et la LPM en elle-même je vous donne
quand même lecture de cette phrase qui a
fait lever les yeux au ciel de certains
collègues quand on a présenté en
commission mais franchement comme dirait
l'autre vous inquiétez pas ça va bien se
passer la phrase est ainsi rédigée cette
dernière alliance s'agissant de l'OTAN
non exclusive ce qui est vrai
factuellement ne saurait empêcher la
France fidèle à sa tradition de nations
présentes sur plusieurs continents et
soucieuse de la coopération
internationale entre les peuples de
nourrir et développer des partenariats
tous azimuts dès lors que ceci servent
ces intérêts autant que ceux des peuples
concernés je pense qu'avec un petit
effort et sans que ça remette en cause
la structure globale du texte j'invite
mes collègues à le voter
et bien nous allons voir donc le 53 2
avis défavorable
par-delà ce que certains peuvent penser
de nos interventions c'est pas une
remise en cause par rapport à l'OTAN
mais il faut pas que ce soit exhaustif
et je crois qu'il faudrait remonter
revenir à certains fondamentaux et ne
pas le considérer comme une offense mais
comme un apport constructif
merci allez cette fois-ci je me vois le
53 avec deux avis défavorables qui pour
qui contre
il est rejeté trois amendements
discussion commune le 267 du
gouvernement défendu le 5 qui le défunt
oui
merci président la commission des
Affaires étrangères a modifié l'article
7 du projet de loi de programmation
militaire a fait notamment de prévoir
son actualisation à la fin 2026 j'avais
également déposé un commission
d'amendement pour que l'actualisation
intervienne au plus tard avant la fin du
premier semestre 2027 mes arguments
n'étaient pas du tout les mêmes que ceux
de la commission qui a souhaité lancer
l'avancée avant 2026 en raison
d'importantes échéances électorales en
2027 pour ma part il s'agissait de
rendre la date plus pertinente avec les
sciences mentionnées dans l'étude
d'impact du projet de loi de
programmation qui indique que
l'actualisation vise à proposer une
réorientation de la trajectoire des
ressources des effectifs pour la période
2027 2030 cet objectif 27 30 implique
effectivement de regarder avec le
Parlement les besoins d'actualisation
dès 2026 pour une éventuelle
réorganisation des crédits de la loi des
finances examinée je le rappelle fin 26
aussi je rejoins la commission sur son
rapport de l'article 7 c'est amendement
vise infinie à corriger par coordination
le rapport annexé pour y mentionner
l'année 2026 comme année d'actualisation
à la place de 2027 si tout le monde a
suivi c'est parfait merci le 24 monsieur
folio
oui merci monsieur le Président
même si nous avons un focus actuellement
sur l'Ukraine et ce qui s'y passe
et cette loi de programmation militaire
anti-inte
malgré tout nous ne devons pas perdre de
vue que les conflictualités de demain
seront très certainement
maritimes elle se dérouleront dans nos
océans pour plusieurs raisons d'une part
parce que si les frontières terrestres
sont à peu près partout bien établis il
est loin d'un être le cas pour les
frontières maritimes qui font l'objet de
contestation c'est le premier point le
deuxième point c'est qu'on voit un
certain nombre d'acteurs notamment la
Chine en mer de Chine du Sud qui par la
politique du fait accompli prennent des
positions qui sont des
positions j'allais dire parfois et même
souvent contraire au droit international
avec tout ce que cela
représente nous avons aussi
des enjeux par rapport aux ressources
qui sont en mer ou sous les mers et avec
les convoitises qui peut y avoir au
niveau d'un certain nombre de puissance
par rapport à tout cela la France a le
premier domaine maritime au monde la
France est la seule puissance
indopacifique donc de l'Union européenne
et donc cet amendement vise à ce que au
niveau donc de cette loi de
programmation militaire a mis parcours
il puisse y avoir donc une
évaluation des menaces prévisibles à
l'horizon 2035 2040 un particulier dans
ce domaine maritime et en lien avec
notre réalité géo stratégique mondiale
et maritime donc sauront commencé à
mi-parcours de cette loi de
programmation les travaux pour un futur
livre blanc on pourrait dire peut-être
bleu portant spécifiquement sur cette
problématique
c'est avis de la commission sur ces
trois amendements monsieur le président
mon amendement de l'amendement du
Gouvernement supprime un alinéa d'un
amendement du groupe CRCE qui en
l'occurrence correspondait au sentiment
majoritairement exprime au sein de la
Commission selon lequel se débat autour
de la révision anticipée de la LPM
n'avait pas permis de questionner à fond
notre modèle d'armée et donc c'est pour
ça que la commission a émis un avis
défavorable à la suppression de la Linéa
par le gouvernement sur l'amendement 5
de notre collègue andriol qui harmonise
la date d'actualisation de la LPM dans
le rapport avec la modification que nous
avons apporté à l'article 7 la vie
c'est-à-dire 2026 notre avis est
favorable de même qu'il est favorable
pour l'amendement 24 de notre collectif
folio pour les travaux préparateurs d'un
livre blanc sur les enjeux maritimes
pour prendre en compte notamment les
tensions dans l'Indo Pacifique donc à
vie favorable sur ces deux derniers
amendements merci avis du gouvernement
alors sur les deux défavorables par
cohérence parce que discussion commune
avec celui du gouvernement après sur le
fond de ce qui était défendu il y a des
choses intéressantes que vous pourrez
reprendre très bien
je vais reprendre donc chacun des
amendements puisqu'ils ne sont pas
identiques d'abord le 268 non 267 du
gouvernement avec un avis défavorable de
la commission qui est pour
qui contre
il est rejeté le 5 avec un avis
favorable de la commission défavorable
du gouvernement qui est pour
il était adopté le 24 avec un avis
favorable de la commission défavorable
du gouvernement qui est pour
qui contre il était adopté et je passe
au 128 monsieur le Président Laurent
nous regrettons profondément l'absence
de stratégie de relance politique en
faveur d'initiative multilatérale de
désarmement alors même que la revue
nationale stratégique constate le
détricotage inquiétant de tous ces
accords au rythme actuel la course aux
armements n'est pas seulement dangereuse
elle ne sera pas supportable elle est de
surcroît dans tous les espaces communs
de l'espace au fond marin en passant par
le numérique alors que l'avenir de la
planète devrait commander de protéger
ses espaces comme des biens communs
inaliénable et des militarisée accepté
comme une fatalité la militarisation
exponentielle du monde c'est participer
à la montée des insécurités mondiales
c'est pourquoi à travers cet amendement
nous vous proposons de faire procéder de
faire précéder notre stratégie
d'anticipation des sauts technologiques
dans le domaine des espaces communs par
l'intérieur nécessité d'une stratégie de
désarmement afin de montrer qu'il s'agit
de notre priorité par ailleurs la
réponse donnée aux besoins oins de nos
armées sera assurés par des filières
industrielles dual qui auront aussi pour
soucis de répondre aux besoins civils et
de coopération les investissements la
matière doivent être placés sous
contrôle public et appuyez par un fond
de financement stratégique de
souveraineté sous contrôle démocratique
cela permettra la mobilisation de
capitaux mixtes soumettant ainsi la
stratégie industrielle aux besoins de la
nation
si avis de la commission
c'est le Président c'est un avis tout à
fait défavorable à cet amendement dont
la rédaction laissant tendre que la
recherche de supériorité opérationnelle
de nos armées alimenterait je cite une
escalade de la militarisation des
nouveaux champs numériques et espaces
c'est tout à fait le contraire bien
évidemment de la même manière considérée
que l'export militaire reviendrait à
stériliser les filières industrielles ça
ça ne correspond absolument pas à la
réalité de nos entreprises de la BITD
pour lesquels les exportations sont au
contraire absolument vitales la vie
défavorable si avec du gouvernement
défavorable
mais au vois le 128 avec deux avis
défavorables pour
qui est contre
il est rejeté le 25 monsieur folio
oui merci monsieur le Président cette
amendement comme d'autres qui suivront
après à nos forces de souveraineté lors
de la discussion générale j'ai dit
combien finalement nous avions eu une
déflation des effectifs en matière de
force de souveraineté ce qui avait une
double conséquence une première
conséquence par rapport à une notion
d'affichage quand on voit les
difficultés que nous avons avec nos
forces de présence et la façon dont nous
avons été exclues d'un certain nombre de
pays au niveau du Sahel et par
définition le caractère aléatoire qu'il
peut y avoir au fait d'avoir des forces
présentes dans des pays avec lesquels
nous avons des accords qui peuvent être
remises en question pour rester en
cohérence avec ce que nous avons
toujours dit ce que nous défendons la
plus particulièrement au niveau du
groupe Union centriste qui est la
volonté d'avoir
une présence donc de nos forces en
matière donc pour exercer de manière
effective la souveraineté mais aussi
au-delà de ça pour avoir des capacités
de projection donc à partir de nos
outre-mer qui seraient un symbole
politique fort et bien nous nous
souhaitons au travers de cette
amendement que soit
mise en réflexion la création de
nouveaux régiment d'infanterie de Madrid
basée en Guadeloupe en maillotes en
Mayotte et en Polynésie avec un objectif
par rapport à cela c'est pas de se
substituer au régime en vigueur où il
existe des régiments de l'armée de terre
mais qui sont le principe des régiments
tournants c'est à dire avec des
compagnies qui viennent pour quatre mois
et qui repartent mais d'avoir à côté de
cela quelques régiment trois régiments
un donc dans les antiques 1 dans l'océan
Indien un dans le Pacifique donc qui
soit basé sur place et avec des
militaires professionnels donc qui soit
sur chacune de ces implantations merci
avis de la commission
le Président c'est une proposition qui
s'appuie sur le rapport d'information du
Sénat sur les outre-mer au cœur d'une
stratégie maritime nationale
alors cet amendement va évidemment
beaucoup plus loin propose qu'il propose
la création de régiment d'infanterie de
marine est-ce que c'est le bon format
pourquoi du reste ne pas les tendre à la
Nouvelle-Calédonie qui peut aussi poser
question nous nous en remettons à la vie
du gouvernement alors avis du
gouvernement oui monsieur le Président
Monsieur Center je vous avais raison les
faut qu'on ait une réflexion globale sur
les forces de présence et de
souveraineté en outre-mer
il y a cet aspect là je vais revenir
dans un instant il y a de manière plus
globale puisqu'on démarre le rapport
annexé l'enjeu aussi dit affecté tout le
saut technologique aussi puisque
malheureusement les forces armées dans
les différents territoires d'outre-mer
sont souvent les plus mal lotis en la
matière alors que c'est précisément là
où le besoin en matière d'imagerie
spatiale de drones typiquement pour
exercer les missions sont absolument
indispensables première chose deuxième
des choses on y reviendra plus tard mais
tous les efforts de remise à niveau
d'infrastructure il y a une priorité
absolue à mettre sur l'outre-mer donc
avant quand même déjà la question de
régiment mais j'y viens tout de suite
malheureusement il suffit de regarder la
base aérienne de la tonutta pour prendre
un exemple calédonien la signatrice
nassimanada reste ici sur les tas des
infrastructures des phase œil par
exemple sur la Réunion qui est un sujet
majeur de toute façon là je pourrais
revenir mais déjà il y a un effort
d'infras et qui comprend aussi le
numérique et l'ensemble de ces sujets
troisième des choses de fait la
déflation des effectifs en outre-mer a
été brutale j'y reviens pas première
élément la fin du service national on
pouvait très bien comprendre mais aussi
dans les années 2000 lorsque d'aucuns
ont pris des décisions de réduction de
crédit très vite on se sont dit à
l'époque au fond c'est en outre-mer
qu'on peut aller taper en premier donc
ça c'est quelque chose qu'on va essayer
de corriger enfin la programmation
militaire globalement on a 950 postes
nouveaux qui sont prévus dans l'ensemble
de la programmation je les avais
d'ailleurs jamais décliné publiquement
donc je le fais 150 aux Antilles 200
Guyane 150 à la réunion sans un maillot
de 200 nouvelles Calédonie et 150 en
Polynésie française mais sur les
structures existantes parce que déjà là
il y a des il y a un peu de un peu de
souffrance je veux dire ensuite d'un
territoire à l'autre les doctrines sont
différentes les deux régiments qui sont
présents en Guyane avec harpie par
définition une doctrine d'emploi qui est
différente vous connaissez ça aussi bien
que moi donc je pense qu'il faudrait le
lauréat dans le détail moi demande de
retrait pour votre amendement parce que
c'est un moment on appelle on écrirait
tel quel effectivement pourquoi pourquoi
forcément troupe de marine regardez en
Guyane vous avez un régiment de Marceau
et un régiment de légionnaires donc bon
enfin je pense que la rédaction là elle
était intéressante pour susciter le
débat je pense qu'il faut pas qu'elle se
retrouve en tant que tel dans la loi la
question se posera ensuite effectivement
du format définitif mais je pense que
c'est pas pour cette LPM ça sera pour
celle d'après parce que de toute façon
on voudrait même créer ces régiments
définitifs permanents que en termes
d'infras c'était mon point précédent en
termes de soutien service de santé scar
etc on n'arriverait pas à suivre voilà
pour donner une vision un peu
panoramique complète sur l'effort
outre-mer dans la copie demande de
retrait le cas échéant mais sur le fond
grand intérêt pour la proposition que
vous avez faite
alors tout d'abord par rapport pourquoi
parler de effectivement de Guadeloupe de
Mayotte de la Polynésie c'est parce que
par rapport à d'autres amendements qui
viendront pour proposer chez dire le
renforcement de nos moyens je pense
notamment nos moyens maritimes ou en
matière aérienne c'était sur d'autres
d'autres implantations et donc c'était
pour avoir un équilibre si si vous
voulez si vous me permettez l'expression
par rapport à cela la logique de de ces
trois implantations et étaient dans ce
cadre-là ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point je voudrais rappeler
monsieur le ministre c'est que l'impact
sur l'économie locale d'avoir des
personnels qui sont des personnels
affectés ou des personnels qui viennent
pour des missions de 4 mois n'est pas du
tout le même
n'est pas du tout le même et que donc
dans ce cadre-là
bien entendu le fait de développer les
forces de souveraineté et tout si un
moyen de soutenir l'économie dont nos
départements et de nos collectivités
ultramarines et chacun sait que elles en
ont grandement besoin parce que ce sont
des consommateurs et et donc qui apporte
donc de l'activité à l'économie locale
donc en fonction des de ce que je viens
de dire et de vos propos monsieur le
ministre j'accepte bien entendu de
retirer cet amendement qui était un
amendement d'appel mais en tout état de
cause la question de fond par rapport au
fait de notre musclé j'ai dire non force
de souveraineté et nos moyens donc liés
à nos outre-mer par rapport au signal
politique que nous donnerons notamment
dans l'Indopacifique en étant présent de
manière plus effective que nous le
sommes aujourd'hui est un message fort
qu'il faudra d'une manière ou d'une
autre donnée merci
deux amendements en discussion commune
d'abord le 129 qui défend oui madame
cet amendement vise l'application de
l'article 6 du traité sur la non
prolifération des armes nucléaires
rentrées en vigueur en 1970 il vise
également ce que la France rejoigne
comme membre observateurs le traité sur
l'interdiction des armes nucléaires ces
deux aspects sont liés en effet
l'article 6 du TNP engage toutes les
parties à poursuivre de bonnes foi des
négociations sur des mesures efficaces
relatives à la cessation de la course
aux armements nucléaires à une date
rapprochée ainsi qu'au désarmement
nucléaire ainsi qu'à traiter de
désarmement général et complet sous un
contrôle international strictes et
efficace le TP est également clair au
regard des obligations de la France
comme des autres pays en effet selon la
Linéa 8 du préambuleux du préambule
stipule que les États partis déclare
leur attention de parvenir au plus tôt à
la cessation de la course aux armements
nucléaires et de prendre des mesures
efficaces dans la voie du désarmement
nucléaire ces dispositions sont encore
plus pertinentes aujourd'hui alors que
les temps sont internationaux sont
croissantes la dégradation de la
situation appelle d'ailleurs à réévaluer
notre politique de dissuasion en lien
avec le respect de nos engagements
internationaux dont l'article 6 TMP
visant des armement nucléaires moutil
latéral adopter cet amendement sur
également être en cohérence avec
l'engagement pris lors du dernier G7 par
les États membres d'approfondir les
efforts de désarmement et de non
proliférations visant à atteindre
l'objectif ultime d'un monde sans arme
nucléaire en cohérence avec ces
objectifs le tian complète utilement le
régime juridique international
interdisant les armes de destruction
massive et ouvrant ainsi la voie à
l'élimination totale de ces armes dans
le monde entier
alors organisation des Nations Unies
l'ONU la volonté de voir appliquer
l'article 6 du TNP a mené en 2016 à des
discussions en vue de négocier un
instrument juridiquement contraignant
d'interdiction des armes nucléaires
conduisant à leur élimination totale
cette volonté a été partagée par la
majorité des pays de l'ONU mais a
rencontré une résistance résolue de tous
les pays qui possèdent l'arme nucléaire
dont la France la France membre
permanence merci
l'amendement 196 monsieur le Président
Gontard
merci merci monsieur le Président
c'était l'amendement équivalent depuis
les progrès considérables des années 70
et 80 le désarmement nucléaire
multilatéral a connu un coup d'arrêt la
fin de la guerre froide éloignement du
risque de guerre nucléaire explique sans
doute cet apathie mais alors que le
spectre de l'apocalypse nucléaire pèse à
nouveau sur l'humanité le vivant et puis
que jamais tant de reprendre ce combat
en 2017 le Traité d'interdiction des
armes nucléaires tient et voter à la
semelle générale des Nations unies à 122
voix sur 192 toutes les puissances
nucléaires ont boycoté ce vote mais
l'ampleur de la demande internationale
en la matière interdit de l'ignorer
royalement comme nous le faisons depuis
six ans pour éviter toute confusion et
tout élément de langage abusif je
rappelle que les écologistes impossibles
de procéder un désarmement unilatéral de
la France aussi nous ne demandons pas à
la France de ratifier le tian nous
demandons à la France de reprendre le
flambeau de la négociation
internationale pour le désarmement
mondial pour ce faire nous demandons que
la France rejoigne le tian en tant que
membre observateur pour pouvoir
participer aux discussions des États
membres qui souhaitent l'abolition des
armes nucléaires cela nous permettrait
d'obtenir des informations de première
main sur les discussions et le
développement relatifs au Tian notamment
suivant les progrès réalisés dans
l'interdiction des armes nucléaires et
en étant informé des positions et des
préoccupations des états partis ou
traités en tant qu'observateur nous
pourrions partager notre position tout
en renforçant nos liens avec des États
participants ainsi qu'avec des
organisations internationales et des
acteurs de la société civile impliqués
sur ces enjeux alors actuel le Traité de
Non proliférations est essentiellement
symbolique nous devons donc prendre
d'autres initiatives vers le désarmement
nucléaire unilatérale si la France veut
poursuivre son rêve d'être une puissance
d'équilibre
œuvré pour le désarmement nucléaire est
une mission diplomatique de la première
importance toute trouvée merci
avide la commission sur ces deux
amendements sur le rapporteur
alors ces deux amendements vise à faire
accéder la France au statut de membre
observateur du trading direction des
armes nucléaires il a déjà été déposé en
commission et débattu et la Commission
en a demandé le retrait au bénéfice
d'une réponse du gouvernement en séance
publique je rappelle que la France n'a
pas ratifié ce traité qu'elle considère
comme contraire à sa position notamment
au regard des efforts particuliers et
intenses que nous produisons dans
l'application de l'article 6 du traité
de non prolifération nucléaire la France
on le sait s'en tient à la stricte
suffisance de son arsenal nous avons
arrêté
le gouvernement arrêté son programme
d'essai nucléaires au profit d'un
programme de simulation nous avons mis
fin par ailleurs à la production de
matières ficile nécessaire à la
construction de tête nucléaires je
propose au gouvernement de compléter
cette réponse et je sollicite le retrait
de ces deux amendements merci monsieur
le ministre le président Cambon a tout
dit la France est engagée dans le TNP et
d'ailleurs vos collègues de l'Assemblée
nationale pour la première la première
fois dans une autre programmation
militaire il va y avoir une référence
très claire au traité de non
prolifération et ça c'était une demande
des groupes écologistes et communiste à
l'Assemblée nationale et je pense que
pour le coup on a un agenda diplomatique
offensif sur la prolifération qu'il faut
tenir
bon il rend n'a pas été beaucoup
prononcé enfin on voit bien quand même
que la menace elle est à nos portes
évidemment la Corée du Nord bref il y a
des sujets évidemment qui sont très
importants à la matière moi je fais
partie de ceux qui considèrent et le
gouvernement évidemment que toute
référence au Tian vient aussi affaiblir
ce qui est fait en matière de
prolifération enfin de lutte contre la
prolifération et que par définition même
un statut d'observateur je trouve non
compatible avec notre doctrine de
dissuasion nucléaire je sais que ce
n'est pas d'accord là dessus mais voilà
en tout cas il y a des références
désormais dans le texte au TNP et ça ça
va pour le coup de l'avant puisque ça
n'a jamais été le cas dans le passé la
vie défavorable
merci je vais mettre voix monsieur le
Président Laurent
sur cette question qui est une question
très importante évidemment nous ne
pouvons que nous féliciter du fait que
la référence au traité de non
prolifération était introduites dans le
texte d'autant que je ne fais de dessin
à personne ici mais la situation
internationale devrait nous inciter à
multiplier les initiatives quand on voit
ce qui s'est passé en Russie il y a
quelques jours ça fait quand même froid
dans le dos de se dire que des gens
comme les dirigeants de Wagner
pourraient un jour accéder à
la possession d'armes de cette puissance
mais ça n'est pas vrai que que chez eux
on a eu des moments dans les élections
américaines qui nous ont aussi donné un
peu froid dans le dos il y a quelques
temps
ou dans la prise dans l'assaut contrôle
Capitole donc on vit quand même dans un
monde où la question de la détention
d'armes nucléaire devrait quand même
beaucoup plus nous préoccuper que ça
semble le cas et quand à l'opposition
qui est fait systématiquement par la
France et d'ailleurs par toutes les
puissances nucléaires avec le tian parce
que aucune des puissances nucléaires ne
veut signer le tion et toute le combat
quelle qu'elle soit la France la Russie
la Chine les États-Unis et d'autres
je pense que c'est totalement faux et
nous devrions nous poser une question
comment est-ce que nous parlons aux
dizaines maintenant plus de 100 États
qui ont signé le tien
quel est le type de dialogue que nous
engageons avec ces pays-là pour les
mettre avec nous dans le combat contre
la prolifération nucléaire parce que ce
que nous proposons là ça n'est pas de
signer l'audience on pourrait avoir
cette discussion c'est d'être membre
observateur de la conférence du Tian
c'est à dire d'entrer en dialogue
positif avec tous les États qui
s'engagent dans cette démarche qui ne
demandent cela absolument pas accéder à
l'arbre nucléaire qui ne sont pas des
États qui cherchent la prolifération qui
sont des États qui ne veulent plus
d'armes nucléaires parce qu'ils savent
qu'ils ne l'auront jamais et qui
demandent qui est un processus
multilatéral plus actif que le sol TNP
or assez pays là nous disons NON NON
comme vous venez de le dire monsieur le
ministre c'est contraire à au TNP mais
non ces pays-là précisément dit ça ne va
pas assez loin il faut prendre plus
d'initiatives et nous refusons d'y aller
avec eux ce n'est pas raisonnable allez
monsieur le Président Gontard
oui merci monsieur le Président je vais
d'abord répondre à monsieur le Président
de la Commission vous avez dit que on
avait eu le débat en commission donc
justement on n'a pas eu le débat et on
avait d'ailleurs signalé qu'on aurait le
débat dans l'hémicycle était important
de l'avoir je pense que voilà il faut
avoir ce temps-là mais c'est vrai qu'on
a pas pour le coup on n'a pas eu on l'a
pas eu en commission je pars reprendre
ce qu'a dit Pierre Laurent mais c'est
vrai que
celui de quand vous nous dites le TNP
effectivement je trouve que c'est une
avancée c'est vrai il a été il a été
inscrit et c'est une avancée importante
donc ça moi je le salue mais justement
et justement quand j'écoute vos
arguments vous parler de l'Iran vous
nous parlez effectivement de ce qui se
passe actuellement autour justement du
du nucléaire je pense que c'est au
contraire justement dans cette situation
là et dans ce moment actuel où on doit
avancer et où à la France en tant que
justement pays qui a une décision
nucléaire peut vraiment je dirais
montrer la voie justement
d'une dénucléarisation et le fait d'être
membre observateur encore une fois et ça
a été rappelé c'est simplement être
membre observateur pour engager du
dialogue c'est uniquement ce que l'on
demande et je ne comprends pas en fait
quand je vous écoute pourquoi ce blocage
là et effectivement pourquoi ce blocage
de l'ensemble des pays qui ont l'arme
nucléaire donc je pense que ça interroge
et je regrette que la France ne soit pas
du coup moteur dans cette dans cette
question là
merci je vais donc mettre voix
maintenant l'abandon 129 avec deux avis
défavorables qui pour
qui contre
rejeté le 196 également deux avis
défavorables qui pour
qui compte
monsieur le président
et merci monsieur le Président alors là
il s'agit d'une autre question nous
proposons par cet amendement la création
d'un commissariat la dissuasion de
demain alternative à l'arme nucléaire
alors tout ça peut peut-être paraître
utopique à certains d'entre vous mais
nous nous considérons que c'est le
moment de se mettre aussi au travail sur
l'anticipation lointaine
si possible d'un autre type de
dissuasion alternative je crois que si
nous le faisons pas
ce sont il y a des scénarios qui peuvent
germer dans des dans des cerveaux bien
bien moins intentionnés que les nôtres
on voit des gens comme Elon Musk alors
je sais bien quel autre mot ce que
maintenant est devenu une star française
mais qui est prêt à gouverner le monde
tout seul et à inventer je ne sais quoi
est-ce qu'on va laisser des cerveaux de
ce type penser
les les grands systèmes de demain y
compris les systèmes de défense et les
systèmes de dissuasion donc je pense que
il va s'inventer beaucoup de choses dans
les décennies à venir nous devrions pas
rester enfermé dans les schémas actuels
qui par ailleurs sont extrêmement
dangereux donc c'est peut-être une
proposition qui peut paraître je le
répète un peu utopique mais qui nous
permettrait de mobiliser des
intelligences pour peut-être imaginer
des scénarios
que personne n'a dans la tête
aujourd'hui mais nous savons que
l'intelligence humaine et les
innovations technologiques sont capables
de beaucoup de choses dans le 21e siècle
donc ce serait une initiative positive
et
utile probablement pour l'avenir
avis de la commission sur le rapporteur
tout d'abord à nos deux collègues y
compris au présent comptable la
commission respecte tout à fait les
positions de vos groupes respectifs et
je rappelle que quand même la Commission
des bas de ces sujets la toute dernière
audition qui a été organisée au sein de
la commission c'est Monsieur Salvetti
qui je crois aide est toujours directeur
des applications militaires du CEA et
qui a donné beaucoup d'informations
beaucoup d'informations sur
l'organisation de la diffusion nucléaire
dans notre pays au point que j'en ai été
moi-même surpris alors sur l'amendement
sur l'amendement 130 nous avons demandé
là encore le retrait de cet amendement
au bénéfice d'un débat en séance
publique avec le gouvernement ce qui a
lieu aujourd'hui je rappelle simplement
que depuis 1960 la dissuasion nucléaire
est consubstantielle à la stratégie
française d'épaulement réciproque des
composantes nucléaires et des
composantes conventionnelles de nos
forces et c'est pas au moment où les
discours et les menaces se multiplient
de la part de plusieurs puissances
nucléaires je pense à la Russie mais
aussi à la Corée du Nord qu'on doit se
détourner de l'enjeu principal que
représente la crédibilité de la
dissuasion nucléaire française donc je
vous propose de retirer cet amendement
après les informations que donnera le
ministre
merci avez-vous du gouvernement monsieur
Président c'est pas tant les
informations que une poursuite de la
réflexion à voix haute ce sont des
amendements qui ont été déposés par la
France insoumise à l'Assemblée nationale
un long débat justement si je le fais en
synthèse il m'avait amené à faire de
commentaires pour essayer de
tirer le fil de l'amendement jusqu'au
bout la première des choses et ça
évidemment on ne peut pas se le
permettre et d'ailleurs vos collègues
députés communistes aussi l'avait
complètement intégré c'est de
sous-entendre que la dissuasion ne
dissurait plus aujourd'hui et demain
parce que le concept même de dissuasion
ne doit pas conduire justement à mettre
en doute sa capacité à dissuader ce qui
explique les renouvellements
que nous avons commencé à avoir hier
premier élément dans la rhétorique parce
que votre amendement est un amendement
au fond qui au-delà de la création d'un
commissariat c'est pas tant la dame au
paladame c'est c'est la réflexion autour
du même du concept de diffusion que vous
portez première des choses déjà pour
dissuader il faut y croire et avoir les
moyens d'y croire première élément qui
mériterait à mon avis d'ailleurs qu'on
passe plus de temps cette réflexion
collectivement la deuxième des choses
vous l'écrivez clairement dans
l'amendement c'est quelque chose qui est
alternatif à la diffusion nucléaire
écrit plus clairement que dans les
amendements à l'Assemblée nationale et
là j'avais donc aussi ouvert le débat à
la réflexion tous ensemble
qu'est-ce qui fait que la dissuasion
nucléaire dissuade c'est parce qu'elle
est fondamentalement terrifiante
je crois qu'il y a pas de doute et que
précisément l'équilibre repose sur ce
sentiment là
et au fond et d'ailleurs les députés de
la France insoumise on avait donné acte
c'est que à réfléchir de quelque chose
d'alternatif à la diffusion de nucléaire
pour avoir le même sentiment tout aussi
terrifiant il y a quelque chose de
proliférant à certains égards c'est de
se dire qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui peut
dissuader autant qu'une arme nucléaire
c'est ça le raisonnement c'est parce que
vous proposez mais si on tire sur le fil
du raisonnement intellectuellement c'est
là où certains de vos collègues
parlementaires la France insoumise
avaient dit mais peut-être que demain la
dissuasion sera spatiale elle sera cyber
etc enfin faut pas qu'on se paye de mots
elle sera toujours pour dissuader elle
aura toujours la même force que la
diffusion nucléaire si elle n'est pas
nucléaire
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président juste
quelques mots d'abord parce que
effectivement le ces amendements
permettent d'avoir ce débat qui a plein
de CV derrière le Président le ministre
pardon
l'actuel ministre des armées pour le
plus précis et je pense qu'il est c'est
vrai que c'est important alors c'est
dommage qu'on l'ait dans ces termes-là
si tardivement mais c'est vrai que il y
a des visions différentes et moi je
pense qu'il est bon que à des moments
donné là en prenant son nationale
s'interroge débats effectivement mais
nous restons en tout cas pour ma famille
poétique extrêmement attachée à la
diffusion nucléaire qui je le rappelle
effectivement et je pense que je vois
que ça c'est simple à démontrer nous a
permis de vivre en paix certes c'est
cette arme terrible et justement c'est
ce côté terrifiant mais par ailleurs ce
côté terrifiant qui permet aujourd'hui
après près de 50 ans une vie
relativement en paix notamment avec les
nations dotées donc ça n'enlève pas ça
n'enlève pas d'autres débats d'abord
parce que on sait qu'il y a la question
de la dissuasion et donc maintenant des
risques qui sont en dessous de la
dissuasion et donc il ferait que la
France comme d'autres
n'agirait pas avec la dissuasion et
c'est une bonne chose d'ailleurs au
demeurant et par ailleurs il y a
effectivement cette volonté et je crois
que il faut l'entendre de réguler de
faire en sorte qu'il n'est pas de
prolifération donc c'est un système
assez complexe mais en tout cas pour
nous il est important pour ma famille
poétique et vous citez souvent générale
de Gaulle je peux citer à mon tour
François Mitterrand sur ce que j'ai dit
hier en discussion générale à savoir que
il considérait effectivement c'est la
volonté d'un homme le chef d'État tout
le reste n'est que matière inerte et je
le raffirme mais il est important je le
redis qu'effectivement nous puissions
avoir ce débat régulièrement mais
l'extrêmement important également que la
France puisse continuer à financer
ça dotation ça sa dissuasion nucléaire
la moderniser
réduire les risques puisque cela existe
et après effectivement il faut que nous
puissions porter un discours de par le
monde sur la question effectivement de
la non pris fédération donc moi je
trouve que c'était ça nous ne voterons
pas ces amendements là parce qu'encore
une fois nous considérons la dissuasion
et la clé de vous notre système de
défense monsieur le Président Laurent
oui moi je ne me demandez pas monsieur
le ministre de répondre à la question de
savoir s'il y a une dissuasion
alternative nous proposons de créer
un lieu qui soit un lieu justement de
réflexion à ça qui permet de se poser
ces questions et il faut se les poser
forcément plusieurs décennies avant de
les mettre en oeuvre parce que c'est pas
en huit jours qu'on invente ce genre de
choses donc il faut réfléchir à beaucoup
de scénarios qui probablement nous
paraissent aujourd'hui improbable
mais je pense que ça vaut la peine parce
que si j'écoute votre discours jusqu'au
bout en gros la dissuasion nucléaire
c'est la fin de l'histoire
c'est à dire il s'avancera jamais rien
d'autre et on finira on est aujourd'hui
avec la dissuasion nucléaire elle est
nécessaire et puis voilà c'est la fin de
l'histoire ça sera toujours comme ça
quand on vous parle
des armements vous dites oh là là mais
on en est tellement loin de
l'élimination des armes nucléaires non
ça vaut même pas la peine d'en parler
quand on vous dit attention nous mettons
le doigt mondialement dans la
militarisation généralisée de l'espace
et des fonds sous-marins vous croyez que
ça va avoir une aucune conséquence alors
qu'on devrait mobiliser toutes les
énergies humaines pour utiliser l'espace
et les fonds sous-marins pour s'occuper
de la transition climatique non on va
les militariser et en plus ce qui les
militarise ce sont des des entreprises
privées comme Elon Musk c'est
extrêmement rassurant moi je pense qu'il
faut penser d'autres scénarios il faut
essayer d'imaginer autre chose de se
projeter dans un autre monde que
celui-là alors ça va pas être demain
matin etc mais je pense que c'est pas
une idée aussi farfelue l'idée que nous
soumettons qu'il y paresse donc on
voulait l'exposer aujourd'hui et je vais
retirer l'amendement parce que le sujet
c'est pas de voter sur cet amendement
mais au moins c'est de mettre cette idée
dans le débat
merci je passe donc au 268 du
gouvernement
oui il est défendu monsieur président
avis de la commission
oui merci Monsieur prison à vie
favorable la Commission avait adopté un
amendement visant à encourager les
constitutions d'un environnement de
données de confiance cet amendement du
Gouvernement entend préciser le contenu
en rappelant que les serveurs concernés
et intéressant la défense respecterait
les qualifications européennes
garantissant leur niveau de sécurité
merci je mets aux voix le 268 du
gouvernement avec un avis favorable de
la commission qui est pour
qui est contre il est adopté deux
amendements discussions communes le 269
du gouvernement sur le ministre
oui il est défendu d'un mot je me suis
déjà engagé devant la commission sur la
réflexion sur l'avenir de sentinelle
postes Jeux Olympiques
après je le redis ici puisque déjà c'est
pas au rapport annexé de fixer les
missions que l'on donne aux armées là
aussi j'en ai si on défend notre modèle
du général de Gaulle à François
Mitterrand en passant par Emmanuel
Macron il est évident que le rôle de
chacun doit être respecté et puis
surtout malheureusement si j'ose dire et
à l'épreuve des faits on en sait tous
quelque chose c'est l'état de la menace
aussi qui doit effectivement commander
le degré de comment dire de projection
des forces sur le territoire national
avec sentinelle en tout cas je voulais
juste redire ici par cet amendement que
les engagements que j'ai pu prendre en
commission sont toujours d'actualité
enfin on l'a vu récemment avec le rôle
de nos armées à Annecy où c'était aussi
d'un détachement de sentinelle qui a
fait partie du premier à marcher pour la
sécurisation des lieux donc j'invite
quand même le Parlement la plus grande
des prudences sur cette affaire de
sentinelle
le 78 monsieur temal ah pardon merci
monsieur
[Musique]
merci alors avis de la commission sur
les deux amendements sur le président
donc sur le 261 du gouvernement la
Commission a estimé qu'il n'y avait pas
d'urgence dans la suppression de
sentinelle des bas en commission du
reste avait précisé que c'est
suppressions ne pouvaient pas intervenir
avant les Jeux olympiques de Paris même
si nous partageons avec la Cour des
comptes l'analyse sur laquelle
l'émission de sentinelle doivent revenir
rapidement aux forces intérieures et non
plus aux militaires qui ne peuvent pas
s'entraîner à la haute intensité pendant
la période de sentinelle donc c'est un
avis défavorable également défavorable
amendement 78 de nos collègues
socialistes nous avons recommandé que
les militaires ne soient plus déployés
dans le cadre de sentinelles tout en
restant mobilisable bien évidemment en
cas de menace graves et nous donnons un
avis favorable à l'amendement 18 de
notre collègue Cédric Perrin qui va dans
ce sens
on n'y est pas encore 18 monsieur le
ministre donc sur le 78 oui alors moi je
l'ai vu comme un amendement d'appel
parce que par définition dans l'article
4 chaque année il y a la communication
qui est due au Parlement pour OPEX mi
sainte et qui évidemment sont-ils de
loin une des missions intérieures les
plus importants alors après moi je vous
l'avais dit aussi en commission si pour
plein de raisons qui vivent aussi
d'ailleurs parfois des fantasmes ou des
ou des propos qui seraient pas exacte
sur sentinelles si vous estimez qu'il
faille dédié même en une demi-heure top
chrono une audition du ministre ou du
chef à major des armées sur le sujet
sentinelle en plus de la communication
qui est faite je pense que ça permet
aussi de d'illustrer les choses parce
que ok il y a la Cour des comptes il y a
tout ça mais enfin après il y a aussi
sentinelle à l'épreuve des faits et dans
la vie des forces et c'est je crois
toujours intéressant que d'éclairer
aussi le Parlement sur comment cette
affaire fonctionne
très bien oui madame Jourdain nous
entendons dans les propos de Monsieur le
Ministre et nous nous retirons cet
amendement dans la mesure où nous aurons
une communication et donc un rapport
lorsqu'il en commission à notre demande
par rapport à ce dispositif très bien il
ne reste donc que l'amendement du
Gouvernement avec un avis défavorable de
la commission qui est pour
[Musique]
il est rejeté je passe au 18 monsieur
Perrin
non alors monsieur delaige
en début monsieur le président
avis de la commission
oui malheureusement je peux pas émettre
un avis favorable puisque le dispositif
juridique parle de réserve stratégique
or non pas de réserve stratégique dans
dans le format des armées
donc je ne vois pas à quoi cela fait
référence si on est d'ailleurs rigoureux
mais je sais que nous sommes tous
le dispositif Sentinel du temps de la
présence de la présidence de François
Hollande d'ailleurs avait déjà fait
l'objet d'un rehaussement de ce qu'on
appelle la faute pour justement
permettre d'avoir le format de l'armée
de terre qui correspond à la mission à
la mission sentinelle et que d'ailleurs
je le note si nous mettion fin un
sentinelle un jour c'est un entraînerait
pas une réduction du format de l'armée
de terre pour autant faut-il le rappeler
donc ça ça fait déjà été prévu par un
certain Jean il voudrions parce qu'il
était ministre de la défense de de
François Hollande donc pour moi c'est
déjà satisfait avis défavorable en tout
cas ça cible un dispositif que je ne ah
bah le Center par un et là en même temps
donc pourquoi réserve stratégique ça
j'ai pas compris et je ne vois pas à
quoi ça fait référence vous demande de
retrait
monsieur on est dans le rapport annexe
donc la notion de réserve stratégique
n'est pas non engendre pas d'effet
juridiques enfin le rapport
Cédric Perrin peut éventuellement
précise
monsieur le ministre
non après derrière j'ai on a 270 000
militaires quand même qui regardent que
nous faisons et qui vont regarder la loi
donc même si le rapport annexé ne
produit pas de d'effet juridique dur
on peut quand même tous s'accorder à
dire qu'il est prescripteur sur le
terrain politique sinon on peut partir
du principe que ça sert à rien de
discuter et de la demander et donc
derrière moi je veux aussi quand même
que ça servent de cadre politique au
militaire pour les armées et d'ailleurs
au-delà même de votre serviteur et
au-delà même d'une alternance politique
en 2027 donc je veux juste vous la
comprendre de quoi de quoi il s'agit
très bien je mets aux voiles amendement
18 avec un avis favorable de la
commission défavorable du gouvernement
qui est pour
merci qui est contre
il est adopté je passe à deux
amendements de discussion commune le 270
du gouvernement monsieur le ministre
et le 120 monsieur Cadic
merci mes chers collègues il est proposé
ici de rappeler dans la LPM que la
France seul pays européen présent dans
l'adopacifique contribue à la défense du
droit à la circulation maritime dans
cette région notamment mère de Chine
méridionale et dans le T3 de Taïwan afin
de préserver la paix et la stabilité de
la région la Chine entretient de
nombreux conflits territoriaux avec ses
voisins Japon Vietnam Filippine Malaisie
et bien sûr Taïwan la recrudescence des
incidents observés en mer de Chine est
liée à une volonté du régime de Pékin de
s'approprier un espace maritime
international
la situation devient très dendue tendue
voire angoissante pour les pêcheurs
vietnamiens régulièrement menacés par
les garde-côtes chinois les sénateurs
Philippins nous ont expliqué au Sénat
que le petit récif baptisé Juan Philippe
est devenu un bouillon de tension depuis
que Pékin le revendique comme son
bastion et il y a construit des bases
militaires sur des îlots artificiels les
incursions chinoises en mer des
Philippines sont désormais quotidiennes
et font la une des journaux locaux les
revendications chinoises sous les
formules d'eau chinois historiques de
zone de souveraineté incontestable et
deux zones de pêche chinoises
traditionnelles ont été invalidés en
juillet 2016 par des décisions du
tribunal arbitral international
constitué à l'initiative des Philippines
Pékin juge la sentence nulle et non
avenue non content de ne pas respecter
le droit international quand il n'est
pas conforme à ses objectifs Pékin
menace directement la libre circulation
du commerce international en affirmant
que les eaux du détroit de Taïwan sont
sous souverainetés chinoise cette
approche prédatrice de la Chine associée
à une marine de guerre qui progresse en
nombre crée l'escalade elle est même
susceptible de déclencher un conflit
international si Pékin rond le statu quo
en tentant d'envahir Taïwan à l'image de
ce que nous observons en Ukraine avec la
Russie voilà pourquoi il est important
que la France défende le droit à la
circulation maritime
avide la ville de la Commission
sur les deux amants
alors sur l'amendement de 70 du
gouvernement qui revient sur l'insertion
de la stratégie Indo-Pacifique française
dans le rapport annexé par la par notre
commission à l'initiative des
rapporteurs donc les suppressions des
zonages proposés
nous paraissent nous paraisse pas
acceptable ne pas nommer les choses ce
ministre ne les fait pas disparaître
qu'on se souvienne ici des réticents qui
ont évité de nommer la Russie il est
fait produit ensuite sur la réputation
les conclusions du rapport de surcroît
les conclusions du rapport d'information
qui ont été adoptés à l'unanimité par
notre commission s'appuie sur un travail
de fond qui ne peut pas être modifié ici
sans une discussion approfondie avec les
rapporteurs donc c'est pour ça je donne
un avis défavorable en l'état mais je
suis prêt en discuter avec le ministre
pour voir si en CMP on peut changer ce
point de vue en ce qui concerne
l'amendement 120 à un avis favorable à
cet amendement qui rappelle
l'attachement de la France à défendre
évidemment la liberté de circuler
dans les eaux internationales notamment
dans le détroit de Taiwan merci Avid du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
je vais donc mettre voix d'abord le 270
du gouvernement avec un avis défavorable
de la commission qui est pour
qui est contre
il est rejeté ensuite le 120 avec deux
avis favorables qui est pour oui
ce caddie il faut lever la main avant
que je mette au bois oui mais
trois secondes merci beaucoup je voulais
vous remercier sincèrement pour ces deux
avis favorables qui sont importants et
qui seront entendus très loin d'ici
merci
donc avis sur le 120 qui est pour avec
deux avis favorables
qui compte
il était adopté le 271 du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre avis de la
commission de monsieur le président
la réaction qui est proposée par le
gouvernement dans cette amendement
supprime l'étude sur l'implantation de
nouvelles bases militaires dans les
drones c'est peut-être une conclusion un
peu rapide à une question qui nous
paraît complexe de la même manière le
gouvernement réduit la Liné à prévoyant
la concertation avec les autorités des
dromcom nous rapporteurs ont entendu sur
place les autorités se plaindre lors de
leur audition de ne pas avoir été
informé par exemple du passage d'un
Rafale en Nouvelle-Calédonie l'évolution
récente de la situation de la Polynésie
française souligne si besoin était que
la méthode appliquée jusqu'ici ne
renforce peut-être pas suffisamment le
lien entre l'hexagone et les territoires
ultramarins la rédaction issue du
rapport d'information sur la place de la
France dans l'Indopacifique qui a été
adopté je le rappelle à l'unanimité tant
de remédier à cette situation et
s'appuie sur un travail de fond et nous
ne pouvons pas le modifier ici en séance
donc en l'état avis défavorable avec
peut-être la perspective de proposer la
prise en compte de certaines
modifications qui pourraient nous être
proposées par le gouvernement avec
l'accord des rapporteurs c'est le
ministre
oui merci beaucoup je vais quand même
redire les choses aussi avec un peu de
gravité parle pas d'informations la
rédaction telle qu'elle était adaptée
par le cogestion en fait ce que propose
le Sénat j'ai quand même lire le
paragraphe je vois bien qu'on ne peut
rien ne modifier en séance mais quand
même il convient d'acclimater la
stratégie de Pacifique nationale en
renforçant sa cogestion avec les
territoires ultramarins français à
laquelle les armées doivent participer
alors moi j'étais mis des Outre-mer pas
me suspecter de complètement
débarqué dans cette affaire je sais d'où
ça vient les familles politiques
indépendantistes de Polynésie française
Nouvelle-Calédonie demande cette
cogestion je l'ai refusé à l'Assemblée
nationale
et pas de cogestion en matière
régaliennes dans notre Constitution
entre une collectivité territoriale à
droite spécifique et le cœur même de
notre souveraineté quel modèle d'armée
alors qu'il faille peut-être que je
prenne une instruction pour que les
comme sup informe s'il y a une escale
d'un bateau etc on peut le faire les
forces armées le font déjà et elle
continueront de le faire pour ceux qui
sont amenés à prendre des commandements
bientôt dans le Pacifique enfin les mots
ont du sens donc cogestion je sais d'où
ça vient deux ans ministre des Outre-mer
un an ministre des Armées cogestion
c'est le mot qui est défendu par les
formations indépendantistes en
Nouvelle-Calédonie en Polynésie
française moi je suis strictement
défavorable à toute forme de cogestion
en matière militaire avec des
collectivités territoriales là je crois
qu'au bout d'un moment faut quand même
il faut quand même qu'on soit sérieux
sur le sur le texte je le redis et ce
n'est pas comminatoire mais donc l'état
d'esprit du moment du gouvernement
c'était surtout de revenir là-dessus si
vous estimez pour une autre raison
monsieur le Président que la maman du
gouvernement n'est pas parfait on peut
donc peut-être sous un mandé pour
enlever le mot que gestion moi j'ai ce
que j'ai demandé à mes équipes dans le
dépôt des amendements du Gouvernement
c'est de reprendre les rédactions
initiales pour ne pas vous perdre en
termes de lisibilité donc en fait là
l'amendement on réinjecte la version de
l'Assemblée nationale pas parce que
c'est la version de l'Assemblée
nationale c'est parce que je voulais pas
refaire une version 3 pour que tout ça
soit lisible pour tout à chacun mais
l'objet qui a déclenché l'amendement
politiquement pour votre serviteur c'est
le mot que gestion et moi je vous le dis
même sur un seul mot comme ça je serai
prêt à défendre cette affaire parce que
là c'est pas notre Constitution c'est
pas le sens de l'histoire il me semble
que c'est presque le Sénat défend
d'habitude donc monsieur le Président
peut-être un sous amendement que je peux
déposer si le président de la commission
mi-autorise aussi souhaite le faire vous
vous souhaitez le faire vous-même ou
moi je vous propose
je vous propose de Sousa mander il
convient d'acclimater la stratégie de
Pacifique nationale en renforçant par sa
cogestion du territoire ultramarins
français à laquelle les armées doivent
participer en renforçant l'information
et on en parle plus mais donc un
amendement de suppression de sacogestion
remplacée par information et là ça
correspond à ce qui se passe déjà et je
pense que c'est consensuel
attendez alors du calme je le ministre
vous ne pouvez pas sous-amender mais en
revanche vous pouvez rectifier votre
amendement alors le problème c'est que
l'amendement du Gouvernement pour le
regarder il est particulièrement long
puisqu'il réintroduisait une autre
rédaction donc
je préférais plutôt amender ou alors
j'amende dans séance si le président de
la Commission on est d'accord
oui c'est ce qu'il faut faire moi je
suis prêt à retirer l'amendement de 171
monsieur le Président parce qu'il est
plus global déposer un amendement du
Gouvernement en séance
tel que je l'ai annoncé
je ne sais pas si le présent va réunir
la commission pour l'examiner mais
je les consulte du regard
et je vous propose donc ce nouvel
amendement du gouvernement mais qui me
semble à la fois constitutionnel et
juste
je donne mon accord sur cette nouvelle
version avec je le crois la sentiment de
la majorité de la commission peut-être
même son unanimité
donc j'en conclus
que le 271 en tant que tel est retiré
remplacé par un 311 du gouvernement qui
modifie comme on l'a dit c'est-à-dire à
l'alinéa 14 on enlève en renforçant sa
cogestion avec les territoires
ultramarins pour mettre seulement en
renforçant l'information des territoires
ultramarins
on est d'accord monsieur le Président de
la Commission parfait donc je n'ai plus
de 271 j'ai le 311 que je viens de vous
lire si je peux dire
très bien je vais donc mettre aux voix
ce 311 du gouvernement avec cette
fois-ci un avis favorable on est bien
d'accord très bien qui est pour
qui est contre
il est adopté
nous arrivons à quatre amendements qui
font l'objet d'une discussion commune
d'abord le 104 monsieur temal oui merci
monsieur le Président cette alinéa vise
à renforcer le lien nation armée et bien
sûr nous sommes d'accord avec ça mais
nous ne pensons pas que cela doivent se
faire au travers du SNU c'est un
dispositif qui de notre point de vue est
mal monté à ce jour peut être actif et
pas encore évalué nous proposons donc la
suppression du passage qui y fait
référence et nous rajoutons que en plus
des réservistes ce sont les élèves des
établissements scolaires qui occuperont
une place importante dans les cérémonies
commémoratives
merci ensuite le 216 du président gonta
oui merci monsieur le Président de la
même manière puisqu'on refait mention du
SMU dans cette dans cette partie du
texte
et donc du coup c'était pour ajouter le
terme volontaire en fait on refait le
débat d'hier voilà
merci
ensuite le 108 madame Carlotti oui
monsieur le Président dans la première
phrase de cette alinéa nous proposons
aussi de supprimer la référence au SNU
et dans le deuxième à la fin on met un
idéal à la fin de la ligne A15 nous
proposons de rajouter que le
gouvernement doit mettre au remettre au
Parlement un rapport au 1er octobre 2023
qui ferait justement état du bilan du
SNU préalablement à toute évolution du
dispositif
merci le 132 madame Brulin merci
Monsieur Madame la
mes chers collègues je crois qu'en
cohérence effectivement avec les
discussions qui ont eu lieu hier si ce
SNU ce service national universel n'a
pas à figurer et pour des raisons
différentes les uns et les autres nous
le considérons dans cette loi de
programmation militaire alors il n'a pas
davantage à figurer dans son rapport
annexé et c'est aussi l'objet de notre
amendement vous le savez nous sommes
opposés pour ce qui nous concerne à ce
SNU tant dans son format que dans ses
objectifs et dans les sommes
considérables qu'il va mobiliser et je
crois qu'il y a d'ailleurs de plus en
plus de nos concitoyens qui considèrent
celui-ci comme un gadget extrêmement
coûteux un gadget présidentiel
extrêmement coûteux qui va se traduire
selon vos propres annonces madame la
ministre par 12 jours de cours en moins
pour les élèves par une promesse de
brassage qui devait être la panache de
ce SNU qui n'existera pas puisque les
élèves de Seconde ils classe entière
dans ce service national universel et
que je sache les classes dans le système
scolaire français ne brasse pas
particulièrement les élèves il y a même
des phénomènes d'inégalités de
ségrégation qui se renforcent ce SNU
nous est annoncé sur la base du
volontariat mais on nous dit quand même
temps
le fait de le faire
apporterait une bonification dans
parcoursup ce qui ne peut pas être
évidemment entendable de notre point de
vue et on nous dit enfin que des
références est recrutées dans le cadre
de l'éducation nationale et rémunéré via
les missions pacte c'est à dire des
missions qui seraient des missions
supplémentaires qui seraient ainsi
rémunéré je crois qu'on vit aujourd'hui
une crise de recrutement des enseignants
qui sont d'ailleurs particulièrement
opposés à ces missions pactes et donc je
ne crois pas qu'on va pouvoir compter
sur eux et enfin la jeunesse s'engage on
en a la démonstration tous les jours et
appuyez-vous davantage sur les
collectivités locales pour voir comment
on peut associer les jeunes j'ai dans ma
région la Normandie les initiatives
Normandie pour la paix et je crois qu'on
peut s'en inspirer merci quand je dis
merci on s'assoit pardon de vous le dire
c'est pas merci ça veut dire qu'on peut
continuer 10 secondes 15 secondes sinon
ça veut plus rien dire deux minutes
tout le monde a la parole mais tout le
monde a la parole dans les règles 2
minutes alors
je passe donc
je suis plus au rapporteur alors
monsieur le président
sur avis de la commission
sur les quatre amendements sur le 104 un
avis favorable puisque c'est un moment
propose de retirer deux mentions faites
au SMU dans des passages du rapport
annexés comme les cellules a fait
l'objet d'aucun débat parlementaire à ce
jour et que sa généralisation
entraînerait beaucoup de conséquences et
d'obstacles juridiques et financiers
donc nous je donne un avis favorable sur
cet amendement sur le 216 la vie est
défavorable c'est un moment propose de
renommer le service national universel
en y ajoutant volontaire le SNU est
maintenant une politique publique
expérimentée depuis 2019 sur la base du
volontariat c'est pas la peine de
remettre en cause une appellation qui
est désormais consacrée et qui rend
préférable pour l'intelligibilité de la
loi l'expression qui est ainsi utilisée
pour le 108 un avis favorable c'est un
moment demande la production d'un
rapport nous sommes pas très favorable à
la multiplication des rapports mais
enfin un rapport au gouvernement au plus
tard le 1er octobre 2023 sur l'évolution
du dispositif car je pense qu'il y a une
véritable appétence du Parlement et
singulièrement du Sénat pour mesurer les
effets et l'utilité et l'application du
s&u enfin un avis défavorable sur
l'amendement 132 qui prévoit de
supprimer la mention de la montée en
puissance du essai nu et la
participation des jeunes du sénu au
cérémonie mémorielle je dirais que c'est
justement l'effet contraires qui se qui
est demandé pour recréer ce lien armée
nation si des jeunes du essai nu peuvent
participer à nos manifestations
mémorielles je pense que c'est plutôt
une bonne chose donc un avis défavorable
merci avec du gouvernement madame la
ministre
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs pour
faire un point un peu général et
reprendre la discussion que nous avons
hier en réalité le service national
depuis 2019 c'est 50 000 jeunes cette
année il y a plus de 10000 jeunes
volontaires sur liste d'attente madame
la sénatrice il rencontre de plus en
plus en réalité de succès que le débat
parlementaire soit nécessaire évidemment
et je suis à la disposition évidemment
de la haute chambre comme de l'Assemblée
nationale pour avoir ce débat ce qui est
certain c'est que on l'a sorti
volontairement de la partie normative de
la LPM puisque le service national est
un service civil aujourd'hui encore
volontaire qui s'appuie sur le
volontariat aujourd'hui exclusivement
des des jeunes et de leurs parents bien
sûr et demain et demain avec la volonté
des enseignants si le souhaitent mais
faisons leur confiance mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs si les
enseignants considèrent que développer
le civisme la citoyenneté en s'appuyant
sur ce projet est une bonne chose pour
eux pourquoi leur priver de cette
opportunité là et puis à ce moment là on
fera une évaluation à la fin de l'année
ça se trouve ça va être un superbe
succès puisque moi je vois des
enseignants extrêmement sensibles à la
question en réalité de mixité
citoyenneté et si au bout d'un an les
enseignants ne se sont passés de cette
opportunité et bien votre service votre
service très sera devant vous taire sera
devant vous pour tout simplement dire
que ça a été une expérience d'engagement
volontaire collectif qui n'a pas trouvé
de succès mais très sincèrement c'est
une opportunité que nous avons travaillé
suite à des dizaines de consultations
d'organisations de jeunesse syndicale
d'associations de parents d'élèves et à
aucun moment quand on part quand on part
12 jours dans un projet pédagogique il y
a une perte d'apprentissage puisque
c'est en complémentarité avec
l'éducation civique et ce qui est
certain et c'est en adéquation avec le
ministre des Armées ce n'est pas dans le
dur de la loi de programmation militaire
ni son ni sur son financement il a des
externalités positives bien sûr parce
que ça vient renforcer le lien armé
jeunesse nation ou plus largement
la crise du civisme que notre jeunesse
vit alors même que sur la reconnaissance
de parcoursup madame la sénatrice
puisque ça a été un des sujets évoqués
aujourd'hui l'idée c'est permettre à
tous les engagements qui soient reconnus
quand on est jeune quand on est jeune
dans un conseil municipal qu'on fasse un
service national universel qu'on soit
jeune élu dans dans le projet académique
de l'établissement c'est simplement
reconnaître aux jeunes qui s'engagent et
bien un petit plus parce que c'est aussi
ça notre notre République voilà mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs avec un avis
pour le coup défavorable sur l'ensemble
parce que le débat sur le cellule n'a
pas vocation et dans l'alpm mais
évidemment la les avis du président de
la commission sont extrêmement
éclairants
bien mes chers amis comme il y a
beaucoup de demandes de parole et vu
l'heure je vais suspendre la séance elle
sera reprise à 21h30 pour les
explications de vote et les votes merci